>>Cliff: So, good afternoon everyone. Welcome
to another awesome Authors@Google talk. Today,
we're particularly honored to host Eboo Patel.
Now, as part of the Campus Honors Program
at the University of Illinois, Urbana-Champaign,
the name Eboo Patel is always displayed prominently
on our walls, it's sort of a myth and legend
thing as, as we progress through the program;
someone larger than life. And that's, to a
certain extent who Eboo is; he's always striving
for the greater good.
He found his calling through the promotion
of interfaith dialogue, making the interfaith
conversation as, as important and relevant
as the environmental con-, conversation, the
social justice conversation, and he's found
his particular outlet on, on college campuses,
which is a, a traditional area for, for discussion
and, and un-, understanding. And E-, Eboo's
team has made a big impact in terms of fostering
interfaith dialogue on college campuses.
Now, his work does reach beyond the college
campus and the University. He serves currently
on the board of President Obama's Religious
Advisory Committee, and he writes regularly
for The Washington Post in a, a blog that
deals with interfaith issues. It's entitled,
"The Faith Divide."
Today, he'll be speaking to us about his work
through his non-profit, which is the Interfaith
Youth Corps, and as well as his book, his
book, which is entitled, "Acts of Faith: The
Story of an American Muslim, the Struggle
for the Soul of a Generation." Now, Eboo has
many titles and awards from being a, a Rhodes
Scholar to an Ashoka Fellow to a, a member
of the, the National Committee of the Aga
Khan Foundation.
He's one of the social entrepreneurs to watch
on our nation's stage, but, but his true merit
lies in his impact in work and by fostering
interfaith dialogue, Eboo helps make the world
truly a better place. So, we'll have some
time for Q&A at the end. Feel free to use
the, the mics and otherwise, please join me
in welcoming Eboo to Google.
[applause]
Thank you.
>>Patel: Thank you. Well, thank you to my
fellow Ilini, Cliff. Thank you, too, Usma,
Mahin, and Cliff, for hosting me for lunch.
Thank you to Google. This, you wanna talk
about legend, this company is legend, this
campus is legend, and I was joking with Usma
and Mahin, and Cliff earlier saying, "I've
long wanted to visit Google, but I felt a
little peculiar about being a tourist here."
So, when I got the, the invitation to come
speak I thought, "Well, you know, this is,
this is my opportunity to kind of get an oogle
at Google, if you will, and see the famous
pool tables and the coffee shops and the cafeterias
and, and the tents and, thank you."
Thank you. Thank you for, for being part of
a generation that envisioned a new world and
then built that world. And that's what we're
trying to do in our own way at the Interfaith
Youth Corps. And I wanna, what I wanna describe
for you is, is where that vision came from,
what that vision is, and how we're trying
to build it. And then what I'd love is your
advice. I mean your advice as a community
of people who, as I said, have imagined a
new world and then built that new world, right?
How, how could you counsel us in dramatically
expanding our reach and our impact?
So, to begin with, I wanna take you back to
a place that Cliff and I happen to share,
which is the University of Illinois, and I
understand that there's a pretty good pipeline
from Champaign Urbana, Illinois to Mountain
View, California, a set of very, very talented
computer engineers who are working here at
Google and I wanna tell you that, that my
year, my time in Champaign was a dramatic
paradigm shift for me. My, and, and the paradigm
shift was largely around issues of identity
and diversity, right? I grew up as a, as a
person of color, an Indian American who's
Muslim in the suburbs of Chicago and, you
know, frankly, I, I spent a lot of time trying
to be white in the western suburbs of Chicago
because that's was kind of the dominant cultural
archetype.
And when I got to the University of Illinois,
I became part of a conversation about what
does it mean to build a truly multicultural
America where people are proud of their racial,
their ethnic, their national backgrounds,
and where they're contributing the best of
those backgrounds to build this, this nation
that has gathered people from the four corners
of the Earth. And the multicultural conversation
was very, very prominent in the mid 1990s
all over the country and including the University
of Illinois.
And like any good 17-year old, first year
student, I would go home to my parent's house
in Glen Ellyn and I would regale my father
with all my newfound wisdom from my first
year in college. And I would lecture him over
and over again about identity and diversity
and my dad would kind of roll his eyes and
be like, you know, "I got my MBA from Notre
Dame University in South Bend, Indiana, and
I was one of the first Indian Americans in
a senior position in corporate advertising.
You think I don't know something about diversity?
And you think I don't know something about
trying to advance multiculturalism?"
My dad said one thing to me, which not only
struck me deeply at that point, but frankly,
changed my life. And he said, "For all your
talk about identity and diversity, you, you
never mentioned the form of identity and the
type of diversity that's driving global politics.
And that's religion." My dad was exactly right.
Think about '93, '94, '95, '96, that mid to
late 1990s.
Think about some of the most prominent global
events during that time. There was the World
Trade Center bombing in 1993, kind of Al-Qaeda's
coming out party, if you will, there was the
assassination of Yitzhak Rabin in the Middle
East, there was the possibilities represented
by the Oslo Process and then the breakdown
of that process, there was a nuclear test
in India dubbed, "The Hindu Bomb," there was
the response in Pakistan dubbed, "The Muslim
Bomb," there was a, a terrible rampage through
Champaign, Illinois and Chicago and Bloomington,
Indiana, somebody who shot and targeted Jews,
Asian Americans, and African Americans.
And each of those incidents of horror, you
know, an additional one is the bombing at
the Atlanta Olympics in 1996, each of those
incidents of horror was perpetrated to the
soundtrack of prayer. It was committed in
the name of God, right? And what's interesting
is that the perpetrators came from different
religions, so Al-Qaeda clearly claims Muslim
heritage. The assassin of Yitzhak Rabin in
1995 was Jewish; claims Jewish heritage.
The person who shot Jews, African Americans,
and Asian Americans in, in the Midwest, was
part of the Christian Identity movement, right?
So, a huge part of national and global politics
was this emergence of religious extremism.
And Sam Huntington, the late Harvard political
scientist, put a framework on this. For my
money, a very dangerous framework. He said
that the next era in human history was gonna
be defined by what he called "The Clash of
Civilizations."
The simple definition of the Clash of Civilizations
is that people from different religious backgrounds
were inherently and inevitably at odds with
each other, right? We were gonna enter a period
of inter-religious war. So, his message to
people from different religions is espe-,
is essentially that people from the other
faith are coming; sharpen your swords, right?
You have to if, if, if, if you don't wanna
die, you have to, you have to prepare to defeat
and kill and win, right? That's the message
of the Clash of Civilizations. And my dad
was exactly right.
There was almost no discussion of this on
my college campus. And Diana Eck, a professor
at Harvard, who writes on religious diversity,
actually pointed out that there was almost
no discussion of religion in the diversity
multicultural conversation nationally. She
says religion is the missing "R" in the diversity
conversation. And not only was this missing,
in kind of a global macro way, it was also
missing in a personal way and there's something
that happened when I was a resident advisor
at the University of Illinois that I, I still
remember.
So, again, this is in the midst in the multicultural
movement where, where we are often invited
to share our identities and to talk about
how we might have met-, been made to feel
uncomfortable because of a certain part of
our identity. So, we're having this type of
workshop as a group of resident advisors at
the University of Illinois and people are
saying, "Well, you know, as an African American,
you know, this happened to me. As a Latino
American, this happened to me that made me
feel uncomfortable or marginalized."
So, it gets around to my friend Kizar and
Kizar says, "You know, there was something
that happened in the cafeteria a couple weeks
ago that made me feel really uncomfortable."
There was a group of student who basically
had a food fight, who kept on getting food
and throwing it around and, and everybody,
including the resident advisors and the cafeteria
workers, they were all laughing and effectively
encouraging this terrible waste of food. And
Kizar said, you know, "For me, food is life
and life is from God and that is precious
because I'm a Muslim and, so I was a little
bit offended by what happened. As I looked
around at the faces of these resident advisors
and these other kind of campus leaders of
the University of Illinois, people who are,
you know, trained to be aware of how people's
identities affect their lives, blank stares."
They weren't opposed to what Kizar was saying;
they just had no radar screen for it. They
had no radar screen for somebody making salient
their religious identity and the role it played
in their lives. And I thought to myself, "Wow.
You know, we're missing a great opportunity
here, right? Because at the global, political
level, the story that's being written is a
story of religions and conflict with each
other. And who seemed to be the perpetrators
of that conflict? Who, who were, were the
foot soldiers of religious extremism?
They're always teenagers and twenty-something's,
right?" I mean, the assassin of Yitzhak Rabin
is 26 years old. Almost all of the September
11th hijackers; in their twenties, right?
Osama bin Laden recruited into extremism when
he's14 years old, right? The person who bombs
the Atlanta Olympics, part of the Christian
Identity movement, is just 30 years old. Religious
extremism is a movement of young people taking
action.
Well, here was this other movement happening
on college campuses of young people who wanted
to be aware, in an appreciative way, of identities
that mattered to people and to bring those
identities into harmony and cooperation, but
we weren't talking about religion. We were
forfeiting that territory to the religious
extremists of the world. I thought to myself,
"You know, we, we oughtta be able to do something
different. We oughtta be able to do something
different."
And, and one of the things that gave me an
awful lot of encouragement and inspiration
was history, you know? So much of the 20th
century's most inspiring movements are actually
interfaith movements started by young people.
So, Martin Luther King Jr. is obviously a
great civil rights hero, he's a great African
American hero, he's a great American figure,
but he's also a great interfaith hero. Now,
King, after all was inspired by Gandhi's movement
in, in India. He marched in Selma with Rabbi
Abraham Joshua Heschel; he carried out a correspondence
that deeply influenced him by a Buddhist monk
named The Venerable Thich Nhat Hahn, right?
King learns from people from a variety of
religious backgrounds even as he s-, remains
deeply, deeply rooted in his own Christian
faith and he learns how to bring people from
different religions together to serve the
common good. The Civil Rights movement is
an interfaith movement. Same with Gandhi's
Hintz Barrage movement in India, same with
the struggle in South Africa, right? Same
with movements like community organizing;
these are interfaith movements.
And so, I think to myself, "If those were
movements that were built of the early and
mid-late part of the 20th centuries, couldn't
we be part of writing the next chapter in
interfaith cooperation, especially in an era
of global religious conflict?" Final inspiring
dimension from history: the people who started
those interfaith movements, they're our age,
younger. King, in Montgomery in 1955, when
he led the bus boycott, was 26 years old.
Mandela, when he founds the Youth League of
the African National Congress; 26 years old.
Gandhi, when he starts the movement against
the racist pass laws of South Africa in the
early 20th century; 24 years old. The Dalai
Lama, when he moves Tibetans into India; 24
years old, right? Well, if interfaith cooperation
in previous eras was a movement of young people,
why not today? Why can't we make the story
of young people's involvement in religious
diversity in the 21st century, not a story
of the Clash of Civilizations, but a story
of interfaith cooperation?
I think religion in the 21st century can go
one of four basic directions. It can be a
bubble of isolation, you can say that your
religious commitment or your, your humanist
commitment, whatever it might be, walls you
off from everybody different and if you're
a Muslim, you can't talk to anybody else.
If you're a Hindu or a Christian or a Humanist,
you can't have any dealings with anybody else
from a different background, so it can be
a bubble. It can be a barrier of division.
Your religion is so different from anybody
else's that you're actually in an oppositional
tension.
It can be a bomb of destruction, you know,
you feel like you need to dominate people
from other backgrounds, violently. Or, it
can be a bridge of cooperation. The 21st century
could lift up the best of the spirit of the
Civil Rights movement, the best of the spirit
of the south-, the, the struggle in South
Africa, the best of the spirit of the Settlement
House Movement in the United States, and say
that people from different religious backgrounds,
including no religion at all, ought to interact
in ways that build understanding and cooperation.
We oughtta be building bridges, right? I think
that there are four main trends in the world
that make this one of the great topics of
our times, right? Trend number one is we're
living during a time of religious revival.
You know, the best sociologists forty years
ago, people like Peter Berger, many, many
other were saying that, you know, religion
is dead. As societies modernize, they secularize
necessarily, right? Well, a lot of those sociologists,
in light of you know, recent movements and
trends and demographics, say that they made
what Berger calls a "category mistake." Modernity
doesn't so much secularize as it pluralizes,
right? And, indeed, what numbers show right
now is that there's, there's religion, as
Peter Berger says, "The world is as religious
as it ever was; perhaps more furiously religious
than ever." Right? Sure, there's a growth
in people who call themselves nonbelievers,
but there's increased fervence in a particular
set of believers, especially in areas of the
world defined by the second trend. The second
trend is the "youth bulge".
We live in a very, very young world. You at
Google are probably hyperaware of this because
a lot of, so many people who are fast adopters
of new Google technologies and approaches
are very young people because they're, they're
the first ones who kind of, you know, they
don't have to go from a landline to a cell
phone. They just go straight to a cell phone
and then whatever the next technology is that
you guys are, are, are developing here. Lemme
give you some stats on this. The median age
in Iraq is 19.5. The median age in Afghanistan
is 17.6. There are more children in India
than there are citizens of the United States,
and none of those places is the youngest place
on the planet. That award goes to Uganda,
right? How are all these young people gonna
view their identities in an era of religious
revival? Are they gonna view them, those identities,
as bubbles, as bombs, as barriers, or as bridges?
Ok, third trend that I wanna make salient
is the breakdown of traditional socioeconomic
patterns. Very simply, for much of human history,
people have expected to live the type of life,
have the kind of job, have the kind of family,
have the kind of socioeconomic pattern, if
you will, that their parents had, right? Well,
those jobs don't exist anymore from, you know,
Kansas City to Cairo to Cape Town, right?
And if the same jobs don't exist then you
can't build a family structure on top of those
jobs, right?
You're, you're seeing entire socioeconomic
patterns, entire waves, ways of life disappear.
And what that does is make identity questions.
"Who am I?" questions that much more acute,
that much sharper, right? Because you no longer
have the same kind of identity in being a,
a worker at a GM factory or being a worker
at a government office in Cairo. So, you're
constantly saying, "Who am I and what type
of pattern, what type of life pattern am I
expected to live?"
The fourth trend, another type of, another
thing you guys are hyperaware of here at Google,
and in fact, a trend that you have dramatically
accelerated, is the increase in interaction
by people from different backgrounds, ok?
So, just about everybody on Earth right now
is aware that there are people who are very
different than them on Earth. And think about
how shocking that is.
If you weren't aware, if, if, if you thought
that the whole world went to church on Sunday,
right, you're entire town of seven hundred
people goes to church on Sunday and then one
person moves in to your town who doesn't go
to church, right? Or you're aware of somebody
on the other side of the world because of
some Google application that puts you in touch
with that person, of somebody who prays very
differently, or doesn't pray at all, doesn't
believe in God at all or believes in a, in
one God fervently, or believes that Jesus
is the son of God when you believe Jesus is
a prophet of God, right?
You start asking yourself two, deep, gut level
questions. Question number one: If that person
believes something differently, why do I believe
what I believe? If the Buddhist kid who just
moved into my town doesn't go to church on
Sunday, why do I go to church on Sunday? Now
what you took for granted because it was your
whole world before, because, you know, all
you knew is a fish was water, right? When
somebody shows you air, you start to ask yourself
the question, "Why do I live in water?"
And the second question it makes salient is:
How do I relate to that person? So, she doesn't
go to church on Sunday. He doesn't pray the
way that I do. She doesn't believe in God
at all. So, what does that mean for how we
relate to each other? Right? So, think of
the intersection of these four trends; the
religious revival, the youth bulge, the breakdown
of socioeconomic patterns, and the increase
in interaction of people from different backgrounds.
And, if you will, personify that for a moment.
Think of the 17 year old kid in Cairo, or
the 17 year old kid in a favela outside of
Rio, or in a township outside of Johannesburg,
or in a small town in Nebraska, right? And
think of the number of 17 year old kids around
the world who can't live the life that their
mom or dad lived, right? Who are asking themselves
all sorts of "who am I" questions and are
now asking not only what does it mean to be
a Pentecostal in Brazil or a Catholic in Nebraska
or a Muslim in Cairo or a Hindu in India,
but what does it mean to be one of those people
in a world of Pentecostal, of Brazilian Pes-,
Pentecostals, Israeli Jews, Indian Hindus,
American Catholics, right? Who am I in this
world? How do I relate to those people? There
is an enormous energy at the intersection
of those four trends and the thing that scares
me is the people who figured that energy out
first are religious extremist movements, ok?
I view extremist movements from Al-Qaeda to
the Christian Identity Movement to their equivalents
in every faith and they have equivalents in
every faith. I view them as effectively youth
movements. They are movements that understand
the psychology of 16 to 24 year olds, understand
the confusion and power and search for clarity
and impact that it as at the heart of what
it means to be at that intersection. These
movements re-, have a clear message to those
young people, "Your religious civilization
was once a magnificent people and look at
us now. We are in the gutter. We're suffering,
but you can return us to glory. All you need
to do is dominate those other people, right?"
These religious extremist movements recruit,
train, network, and mobilize young people
to be the foot soldiers of religious extremism.
That's why on the evening news tonight, and
tomorrow night, and the next night, you're
gonna see some story of some young person
killing other people to the soundtrack of
prayer. It's no accident that they're young.
They were recruited young. They were trained
young. They were mobilized young. The Interfaith
Youth Corps is a movement that wants to turn
the tide. We wanna change the story. We see
a movement of young people taking up the mantle
of King, and Jane Adams, and Dorothy Day,
and Mother Teresa, and Abraham Joshua Heschel,
and Nelson Mandela; a movement of young people
who believes in a world of pluralism, who
believes in a world where people from different
backgrounds live in equal dignity and mutual
loyalty.
A world where people's identities are respected,
a world where there are positive relationships
between people of different communities, and
a world where those people are coming together
to serve the common good. We call that a world
of pluralism. That's the world that we're
trying to build, right? We would like interfaith
cooperation to be a social norm in the same
way that environmentalism has become a social
norm, in the same way that service learning
has become a social norm, in the same way
that the human rights movement is a social
norm.
When you walk out onto the street, the Google
campus is a unique chakra of the world, so
let's not use you guys as the, as the test
case here, but let's say you were to walk
some miles in any direction. You tap somebody
on the shoulder and say, "Human Rights Movement."
They would know what you were talkin about.
"Environmentalism." They would know what you
were talkin about. They would say, "Yeah,
that's a good thing. The Earth is precious
and it ought to be protected and, you know,
I recycle and I drive a hybrid car and we
compost at my home. I participate in this
thing." What would it look like for interfaith
cooperation to have the same clarity of definition?
To have the same participatory culture? Where
you walk out in the street in ten or fifteen
years and tap somebody on the shoulder and
say, "Interfaith cooperation," and the, the
person says, "Yeah, you know, people from
different religious backgrounds including
no religion at all, they ought to be coming
together in ways that build understanding
and cooperation."
That's the definition of interfaith cooperation
and, and I'm a part of that. You know how
I'm a part of it? Because I, I have a knowledge
base of, of how different religions speak
to service, right? So, I don't get my, my
information on Islam from the evening news.
I don't get my information on Judaism or Hinduism
or Evangelical Christianity from the evening
news. I have an appreciative knowledge of
the world's religions, including humanism,
right? I, my church or synagogue or mosque,
we're part of a congregational exchange, right?
My 15 year old son or daughter, he or she
participates in Interfaith Habitat for Humanity
builds four times a year as part of the youth
group of our temple. The college campus that
my 19 year old daughter is on, she's the leader
of the Interfaith Student Council. The mayor
of Mountain View or the mayor of Palo Alto
or the mayor of Chicago, they hosted their
eighth annual Day of Interfaith Service and
this year it had eight thousand people, right?
That's the kind of texture that I'm talking
about for interfaith cooperation being a social
norm. It means people have a framework of
what it means to build interfaith cooperation;
it means they have a knowledge base of how
different religions speak to service and what
it is in their own tradition that would inspire
them to cooperate with others. And they have
a skill set. They have the ability to bring
people from different religious backgrounds
together to build understanding and cooperation.
That's interfaith cooperation becoming a social
norm.
We think that there, that, that we can advance
three core strategies against this. Obviously,
in any movement that becomes a social norm,
there are a thousand organizations. There
are a million different niches. Environmentalism
has, you know, people who chain themselves
to redwood trees and people who buy hybrid
cars and people who start recycling programs
in elementary schools and people who give
money to the Sierra Club, right?
There are a million riffs on environmentalism,
but everybody knows that at the end of the
day, what they're about is that the Earth
is precious it ought to be protected, right?
For interfaith cooperation to become a social
norm, it has to be a field and a movement
that's as diverse and large and robust as,
as any other movement; as environmentalism
or human rights or civil rights or service
learning. We would like to advance three key
strategies.
Key strategy number one: We need to spread
a message and shape a discourse around interfaith
cooperation. Part of what I woke up and realized
a couple years ago is every night, Al-Qaeda
advertises "religion is violent" on the evening
news for free, right? If you want a commer-,
if you're a toothpaste company, or a cola
company, or a car company and you wanna get
your message out on MSNBC or CNN or NBC, you
gotta pay $50,000 for 30 seconds or $200,000
for 30 seconds, but if you're a religious
extremist group, all you have to do is videotape
your beheading and send the videotape to a
media company. And the media company plays
it for free.
Now what that effectively is, is an advertisement
for "religion is violent." So, what that means
is there's a lot of people who walk around
the world and all they know about religion
period, or somebody else's religion, is that
videotape, and I think that that's terrible,
right? What does it look like for those of
us who believe in interfaith cooperation and
who believe that religion can be a bridge
of positive cooperation, to be as aggressive,
as strategic about advancing our message of
interfaith cooperation, of religion as a bridge,
through media and policy circles? What does
it mean for us to, to shape a discourse that,
that says that religions, although they have
clear doctrinal differences, also have very
important shared values? Show me a religion
that doesn't value mercy. Show me a religion
that doesn't value compassion, hospitality,
service, right? The message that we have to
send is that religious communities can come
together on these shared values.
Those values are mutually enriching and they
are actionable and that ought to be part of
the character of the next era. We cannot forfeit
the, the space of the media or the policy
to people who believe in the Clash of Civilizations.
We have to make sure that that space is imbued
with the message of interfaith cooperation.
Strategy number two: We believe a sector needs
to show what "good" looks like, you know?
One of the things that I love about Google
is that, in so many ways, this is a company
that shows what "good" looks like; how it
should treat its employees, right?
And so many other companies have had to follow
the lead of Google to the benefit of the workforce
around the country and the world. We think
that college campuses can show what "good"
looks like when it comes to interfaith cooperation.
Just like college campuses that are around
multiculturalism and sensitize people to the
importance of, of ethnic and racial and national
identity, and sought to build a culture where
people from different racial and ethnic and
national backgrounds were coming together
in a spirit of cooperation.
College campuses are places where there are
different religious student groups; where
there's a volunteer office, where there's
an ethos of leadership development, where
there is a, a sense of being on the vanguard.
Why shouldn't every college campus consider
it part of its mission to model interfaith
cooperation? Every college campus has days
of interfaith service. College presidents
give inaugural speeches to the freshman class
about the importance of religious diversity
and engaging it positively. Well, there are
academic courses that builds peoples knowledge
base and skill set in interfaith cooperation.
Orientation leaders, our age, are trained
in religious diversity and interfaith cooperation,
right? College campuses can show what "good"
looks like.
And that has, there are two clear benefits
to that. One, is it's a sector that other
people follow, ok? I'm pretty convinced that
if college campuses show what "good" looks
like, the corporate sector will follow, high
schools will follow, municipalities will follow,
right? Higher education likes to serve as
the vanguard. I think they ought to serve
as a vanguard in this area.
The second thing is that higher education
trains a nations next generation of leaders.
So, if you have a generation of leaders who
are imbued with the importance of interfaith
cooperation, who develop some of the knowledge
base, who acquire the skill set of interfaith
cooperation, not only do they have a chance
to practice that on their campuses, but they
go ahead and bring that into the culture when
they graduate. And they take it their neighborhoods
and to their communities and to their companies;
they become interfaith leaders.
And that's the third part of the Interfaith
Youth Corps strategy. We need, just like the
environmental movement has a, a critical mass
of people called "environmentalists" who are
driving it, and the human rights movement
has a critical mass of people called "human
rights activists".
For interfaith cooperation to become a social
norm, we need to have a critical mass of people
who are called "interfaith leaders." We need
to have an identity category that people can
i-, that people can relate to, consider themselves
a part of, be in a community within, and that
identity category says, "It's our job to advance
this ethos, this quality, across the planet."
One of the most important movements of the
past 25 years has been social entrepreneurship,
and one of the most important conventions
of that movement is simply the identity category
titled, "social entrepreneur," right? You
have a bunch of people around planet Earth
who say, "Hey, I'm a person who dreams new
dreams for the social sector, for how the
world can be better, and I put those dreams
into action. That means I'm a social entrepreneur.
That means I'm in this community of people
called social entrepreneurs, right?"
We need a community of people called interfaith
leaders and there needs to be enough of them
in neighborhoods, and on campuses, and in
companies across the world to help make interfaith
cooperation a social norm. So, here is where
I would love the help of Googlers. Why it,
it, it strikes me that so much religious extremist
messaging and recruitment takes place online,
right? This is where so many young people,
especially, develop their identity of religion
as a barrier or as even a bomb. How do we
use the online space to send the message and
build a community of religion as a force for
interfaith bridge building?
That's what part of what I'd like to focus
the discussion on, but before I go on to that,
I wanna leave you with, with a piece of one
of my favorite poems by Williams Stafford,
a great poet of the West Coast, a native American
poet, and he says in this, in this beautiful
poem called, "A Ritual to Read to Each Other,"
[quotes from poem]
"If you don't take the time to get to know
me
And I don't take the time to get to know you
Then a pattern that others made may prevail
in this world
And following the wrong God home, we could
miss our star.
Those who are awake must be awake now
Or else a falling line will lull us back to
sleep.
The signals we give--yes or no or maybe--
Must be clear now because the darkness around
us is deep."
Thank you for having me at Google. I look
forward to the conversation [ ].
[applause]
>>Cliff: So, we do, we do have the, the mic
if, if people have any, any questions to,
right there.
[pause]
I guess, I guess one, one question that I
had is, in terms of, of really making, making
people aware beyond the college campus, how,
like what, what concrete steps should people
take when they, you know, move to a corporate
America where--
>>Patel: Right.
>>Cliff: the atmosphere is, is different,
or like people in their middle age--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm.
>>Cliff: or senior citizens? How, how can
we continue the interfaith dialogue--
>>Patel: Right, well--
>>Cliff: later in years?
>>Patel: Cliff, lemme, lemme ask, lemme, lemme
respond to that in two ways. Number one, I
think one of the best ways, obviously, of
getting, spreading the message is, is through
communications in media. What I would love
your advice on is what does it look like to
create online platforms to this kind of civic
goal of interfaith cooperation? And one of
the things that strikes me is, as I was sharing
with you at lunch is, you know, I write a
blog for The Washington Post called The Faith
Divide and I write for USA Today. With some
frequency in the Sunday Times of India and
I, and I write for the Huffington Post and,
and the vast majority of the comments on those
articles and blogs are hateful, right?
And, and they're just, I mean, there's, they
range between "Islam is evil" and "religions
are fated to fight," and I, I think to myself,
"Th-, that can't be representative of the
vast majority of people, right?" Because you,
you don't necessarily see that poison in direct
human discourse and clearly, there are things
about the online world which make it easier
because of anonymity for people to say terrible
things they might not say to somebody's face.
But, how would the smartest people in the
online space think about spreading a message
and creating an online community of people
who believe in interfaith cooperation, given
my very real experience of people responding
to, you know, frankly, noncontroversial pieces
about the importance of interfaith cooperation?
And I don't, you know, my job is not to take
controversial policy stands, it's just to
hold up the idea that religion can be a bridge
of cooperation and what people said about
that, like I said, it's, it's, it's unbelievable.
So, that's one way of spreading this. Lemme,
lemme give a more direct answer to your question,
which is you know, just like I think college
campuses are a great place to do interfaith
service projects. You have 12,000 people here
at your Google campus at Mountain View, right?
Do an interfaith service project amongst Googlers
and, and have it be open to people who, who
are Muslim and Jewish and Evangelical and
Catholic and Hindu and Buddhist and Humanist
and say, "Part of what it means to have an
interfaith service project is not just to
gather the organic diversity of Google together
to, to clean rivers and tutor children, but
to have an, to have a facilitated discussion.
This is what we do. We train these facilitators,
have a facilitated discussion about how people's
various faith identities and religious traditions
inspire them to do service. So, effectively,
you're using a service project as an opportunity
to have a discussion about how religion is
a bridge of cooperation, and the shared value,
and the, and the, and the pragmatic action
project of serving others, right? I think
you can do that in a city. I think you can
do that on a campus. I think you can do that
at Google and I hope you do.
[pause]
>>membermale1: I've read your book.
>>Patel: Oh, thank you.
>>membermale1: And, in fact, a whole group
of people through my church read it. We've
read it; we have an ongoing discussion group
called, "God's Politics," inspired--
>>Patel: Ahh.
>>membermale1: by Jim--
>>Patel: Wallis.
>>membermale1: Jim Wallis and Sojourners.
And I grew up in the Midwest, so I relate
somewhat to your, the, the book says, about,
I grew up in a much more nondiverse community;
a little town. One of the things I see that
with my son's generation is that they are
seeing religion as a very divisive issue --
>>Patel: Yeah.
>>membermale1: And they say, "Heck with it.
All it does is make people angry. All it does
is make people fight. All it does is kill
people, so I don't wanna have anything to
do with it." And so, to bring up anything
about religion, even my boys who went to church,
but don't want to now, is, is divisive to
even mention that idea. So, I'm, I'm not sure
it's the big atheist movements, like Richard
Dawkins and the people who are so strong against
religion are the problem, but the people who
are just sort of seeing religion as not a
force for "good", but a force for--
>>Patel: Right, right.
>>membermale1: for destruction.
>>Patel: Right. So, thank, thank you for that,
that comment. You know, I, I actually have
many more "B's" than before that I listed,
you know. So, I listed religion as a bubble,
as a barrier, as a bomb, and as a bridge.
I think the fourth one, and an increasingly
prevalent one, is religion as blas, right?
I-, people who just don't wanna have anything
to do with it and I think that that is one
of the consequences of, of religious violence
playing out in the evening news, and it's
one of the consequences of people from other
faiths denouncing people of different faiths.
And I think that in a way, any of us who are
religious, or anybody who has a friend who's
religious, right? Who ha-, is, has an appreciation
of tha-, of, of how precious that identity
is to that friend, to say, "Gosh, you know,
it's, it's wrong and damaging and false to
only have the story of religion as poison
and violence out there." You would not have
had a civil rights movement if you didn't
have the religious inspiration. It's the power
of the Montgomery Bus Boycott.
They met in churches, they sang, they sang
gospel songs together, they called it a movement
of Christian Love. King said Jenu-, Jesus
first the inspiration and Gandhi, a religious
Hindu, gave us the message. I saw Nelson Mandela
speak in Cape Town in 1999, and he said, "I
would not be standing here today if it wasn't
for Christians and Muslims and Hindus and
Jews and Traditionalists in Africa coming
together to build a struggle against apartheid."
Right? So, I just think it is, it is a terribly
sad thing if this generation passes on to
the next generation that religion can only
poison things and therefore, you shouldn't
touch it at all. What we ought to be passing
on is religion can be a real force for "good",
but you have to make it a force for "good."
Right?
And in order for you to make it a force for
"good," you can't forfeit it into the hands
of bad people. That's a big part of the message
of the Interfaith Youth Corps, is to, is to
lift up that message and to empower young
people who ba-, wanna believe in religion
as a force for "good" in their own lives,
in history, in the lives of their friends,
to make it so. Thank you.
>>memberfemale2: So, there have been recent
talks about building a mosque at Ground Zero
in New York,--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm
>>memberfemale2: and I read in the news that
there have been protests, where people have
essentially gone with signs that say stuff
like, "Building a mosque at Ground Zero spits
on the graves of 9/11 victims." So, to that
end, what do you think the residents of New
York could do--
>>Patel: Right.
>>memberfemale2: to build bridges?
>>Patel: Right. I think, so I think that's
a great question, so lemme, lemme offer a
story and then platform off that story into
a more direct response to this. So, when Keith
Ellison, who's a friend of mine and the first
Muslim to get elected into Congress in American
history, from the fifth district in Minnesota
representing Minneapolis, when people started
to, when some people said, "We shouldn't have
a Muslim in Congress and we definitely shouldn't
let him take his oath of office on the Koran,"
Keith Ellison's response was to walk across
the street to the Library of Congress and
to request the Koran reverently owned by The
Honorable Thomas Jefferson, and to take his
oath of office on that Koran, right? And the
message he was sending is that religious diversity
and interfaith cooperation was part of the
founding ideals of this country. And by suggesting
that there shouldn't be a Muslim elected to
Congress, or that "I shouldn't take my oath
of office on the Koran," is actually violating
a core American value.
So, I don't want to call you just an Islamaphobe,
I wanna call you somebody who is advancing
a message that's anti-American, right? You
know, George Washington carried out a correspondence
with the Hebrew congregation of Newport, Rhode
Island, and this, this, this Jewish leader
sent him a letter saying, "In this new country
called America, are my people safe here?"
And Washington says, "This nation will give
bigotry no sanction." Right? That's as American
an ethic as you have, that, that diversity
oughtta flourish and oughtta become cooperation.
And I think that that's the message that not
just the Muslims of New York, but that the
people of New York oughtta bring to the people
who are violating that message. That you're
being a-, by, by saying that a group of people
cannot build a house of prayer here, you're
violating the ethic of Washington, you're
violating the ethic of Jefferson, you're violating
the eth-, ethic of Madison, Franklin, and
those people who built this nation. And you
don't know anything about Islam, but that's
point number two.
>>memberfemale2: Thanks.
[pause]
{background chatter]
>>Patel: I'm at Google; I have all the time
in the world.
[laughter]
>>membermale3: One, one of the big concerns
that I have about, I'm sorry. Most religions
have their core in exclusivism. I've read
the Bible, I haven't read the Koran, but I've
read other religious writings and so many
of them have, at least as part of it, saying,
"We are the good people, everybody else is
the bad people." Maybe they said that 2,000
years ago, but in Islam, I don't know, but
in the Bible, clearly it says in parts of
Genesis, "kill all the people who aren't,
aren't Jews." And people use that all the
time. How do we get be-, my own religious
group is Lutheranism and there's a group of
Lutherans who refuse to have anything to do--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm.
>>membermale3: with people who are not their
particular brand of Lutherans because even
working with them together is a sign that
somehow they're--
[Patel clears throat]
sanctioning somebody else's belief as being--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm.
>>membermale3: valid. And how do you, how
does one get to people who--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm.
>>membermake3: have that mindset that, "I'm
right and everybody else is wrong?" There,
there jokes about it, of course--
>>Patel: Right.
>>membermale3: but it's serious and I think--
>>Patel: Mm-hmm.
>>membermale3: I think it's so easy for people
to fall into, how do you--
>>Patel: Right.
>>membermale3: how do you start opening up
dialogue with people who start from there?
>>Patel: Right. So, lemme, lemme tell you
a story. It's a great story about a Christian
pastor who is sta-, American, who is stationed
in Europe during World War II, and his congregation
sends him money so that he can make the voyage
back to America to spend Christmas with his
family and his, his church community.
And he uses that money to help a group of
Jews flee from Hitler's fires into safety.
And one of his congregants writes and says,
"But they weren't even Christian." And he
writes back and says, "Yes, but I am." Right?
And what strikes me about that is, is here
is somebody who says at the heart of my faith
is standing up for people from a different
faith.
And you know what? That's a theology. That's
not just that guy was a nice guy. That's the
Good Samaritan story, right? That's Jesus
reaching out to the marginalized and so, where
I would begin is not so much arguing point-counterpoint
with people who have what I would call a "theology
of separation" or a "theology of domination",
I would just lift up the theology of interfaith
cooperation. And I would say, "Look, there
are parts of the Cription-, of the Christian
scripture and moments of Christian history
that clearly sacrilize, make holy, cooperating
with people from different religions."
Those are the parts that I, I relate to and
want to make real. That's not to say that
there aren't other parts, but you know, the
Bible is a big book, you know? Muslim history
is 1,400 years long, right? There are clearly
contradictory dimensions to, to both scripture
and to the history of a religious tradition.
And at the end of the day, adherents of different
traditions, whether its Hinduism or Humanism,
choose which parts of that tradition that
they're gonna emphasize, that they're gonna
be inspired by, right?
Khaled Abou Al-Fadl, great Muslim theologian,
Usma was talking about earlier actually, you
know, he writes a beautiful essay on this
called, "The Place of Tolerance in Islam."
Where he says, you know, here are the scriptures,
here are, here are the parts of Muslim scripture
and the places in Muslim history that emphasize
domination, right? And then he says, here
are the parts of scripture and the places
in Muslim history which emphasize cooperation,
right? And then he says, so how do you choose
which one is more important? And he goes through,
you know, a set of kind of, more technical,
theological approaches which say, you know,
there are certain verses which are, you know,
de-emphasized for his-, because they're historically
bounded in other verses which are considered
eternal, etc., but then at the end of the
essay, he says something that so powerful
to me.
He says, "You know what, at the end of the
day, the Koran will morally enrich the reader
to the extent that the reader morally enriches
the Koran." Right? At the end of the day,
God has written kindness in the human heart
and the human heart is meant to approach a
religious tradition in the spirit of kindness.
That's what Khaled Abou Al-Fadl is saying.
He says, "That's Muslim theology." Right?
It comes from surah two of the Holy Koran,
in which God says he created Muslims, he created
humankind as his "abden halifa", his servant
and representative on Earth. God gave us his
breath, his rule: we tend towards the good,
as the Muslim tradition says, and we act on
those dimensions that we consider "good" in
the scripture and in the tradition, right?
So, I, I don't wanna get into, you know, a
theological like, you know, sword wielding
match with people who have a theology of domination.
I would much rather lift up and make salient
a theology of interfaith cooperation and,
and say to people around the world, most of
whom are good, right? I share that belief
with, with Google that people are good. The
more you lift up that positive theology, the
more people will, will relate to it. And,
and I think that, you know, to be a little
bit sharp about this, I think we have failed
to do that, right?
And I'm always struck that people who believe
in, in, in, in the bubble, the barrier, or
the bomb, they can quote chapter and verse
on why they believe that. Bang, bang, bang.
They have it on the tip of their tongue, but
those of us who believe in the bridge we don't
really, we can't really cite, you know, surah
49 of the Holy Koran says, "God made us different
nations and tribes that we may come to know
one another." Right?
From, from the Constitution of Medina, right,
where the prophet Muhammad made the peace
and blessings of God be upon him, created
a framework where people from different religious
backgrounds would come together in one city
in Medina through the great Muslim empires
of Cordoba, and the Fatimids, and Bagdad through
Akbar and the Ottomans, through what Rwandan
Muslims did in the genocide, you know? The
Muslim communities have often built partnerships
and, in fact, stood up for people who are
different from them.
That's what I wanna act on, right? And it's
the same in Judaism, it's the same in, in
Christianity, it's the same in Hinduism, it's
the same in Humanism. Lifting that up, teaching
that theology, I think that, that that oughtta
be a high priority.
[pause]
>>memberfemale4: Hi. I just wanna say thanks.
Great subject and a good discussion to have.
I was a member of an interfaith group in college,
so I want to thank you for supporting the
movement, but one problem we had, or that
I observed in our small group, was we had
a lot of people from different faiths, but
we didn't have anyone like you said from the
humanist movement or people without a religiously
defined faith. So, how do we make sure that
we reach out to those groups who don't necessarily
have a religion and make sure they're not
turned off by the mention of faith?
>>Patel: Yeah. I think that's a great question,
thank you for that. So, I, I think part of
it is language and, and you know, I've gotten
better at this and so I, I include humanism.
It's not a religious tradition, but it is
indeed a tradition, right? And it's a tradition
that has, has books and heroes and, and inspiration
for people to cooperate and serve. So, just
including that in our language I think is
important. There are leaders of the humanist
movement, like my friend Greg Epstein, who's
the Humanist Chaplain at Harvard, who you
oughtta invite to speak here, who has written
a book called, "Good Without God," where he
talks about how Humanists ought to be involved
in interfaith cooperation and interfaith service.
And so, use of language is important, issuing
the invitation to Humanists is important,
and finding the leaders of the Humanist Movement
who are pushing interfaith cooperation as
a priority; those are three ways to do that.
Thank you.
[pause]
Nobody's giving me advice on how to build
an interfaith movement online!
[laughter]
>>memberfemale5: I don't know how to build
an, a--
>>Patel: Aren't' you Googlers supposed to
be problem solvers?
>>memberfemale5: But I, I actually had one
thing and I, I don't want, I hope by the name
it doesn't sound like, degrading. I don't
know too much about it, but I'm in engineering
department and someone that I don't work directly
with, but is also in that department recently
went to a fairly major conference in New York
called, I don't know what it was called, but
it was regarding something called "Serious
Games", and he mentioned that with these things
called serious games, which are somewhat like
education games, but less, the education is
less directly in your face. It's a little
more appealing, I guess, to kids--
>>Patel: Yeah.
>>memberfemale5: a little more playing than,
you know, kind of a fake set up and they say
this is a game but it's actually a math problem,
right? But he, he mentioned that there's people,
you know, from all different subjects and
movements and a lot of social activists and
different things doing, with ideas in the
realm of, of, of what they're calling serious
games and I don't, I don't build platforms,
but that's just something that struck me as
you were talking and I, I've been trying to
think for the last five minutes of the name
of, I've forgotten it, but it's something
in the serious games that took place, I think
largely in the San Francisco Bay area, but
with environmentalism in which people, I don't
know, I watched a YouTube video on it, but
they, they pretty much, it was like a real
life game and they took, they took, they pretty
much videotaped themselves, put it on YouTube
through the game, I can't remember the name
of.
When they were, you know, of different actions
they were taking to help the environment and
it was kind of made into a game with people
across the city playing this game for environmentalism.
I don't know, I'd have to be--
>>Patel: I, I love that, I mean this is, that's
actually exactly the kind of, the kind of
advice I'm looking for is, is part of what
you have to do in, in the online space is
things like, figure out where young people
already are and how you can weave messages
like interfaith cooperation into things that
they're already involved with. So, it, I love
to hear that environmentalism is being woven
into games and I think you could do the same
with interfaith cooperation.
>>memberfemale5: Right.
>>Patel: Right, like, so, so you could be
an interfaith leader online and, and kind
of mimic talking to the leader of a synagogue
about how to get their synagogue involved
in an interfaith project, right? I mean, that,
that could be an online kind of interaction,
so--
>>memberfemale5: Right.
>>Patel: Thank you for that. It's a great,
great suggestion.
>>memberfemale5: Sure. So, yeah, it's called
Serious Games and there's some other, some
other things related, but that's the name
that jumps out at me. The other thing is that
I'm here for the year, but really I'm a, I'm
a teacher most of the time and I was just
wondering what, what kind of things are being
done through your organization or other similar
ones, like more at the high school level.
Because, I mean, you can keep going down forever,
but--
>>Patel: Yeah, yeah.
>>memberfemale5: I know that high school students
do go on to
>>Patel: Yeah.
>>memberfemale5: college, and I know high
school students who have started groups based
on race and things, things like that, so I,
are there things being done at high schools?
>>Patel: Yeah. So, so, we don't do a ton of
direct work with high schools. I mean, occasionally,
I'll be asked to like, be the Martin Luther
King Jr. Day speaker at a school and, you
know, I, I'll do it if I can, I, but I clearly
enjoy that stuff.
>>memberfemale5: Mm-hmm.
>>Patel: Not afraid of the microphone, as
you can see.
[laughter]
But part of building a movement, a part of
a movement is that different organizations
emerge and kind of drive different dimensions
of work, and so I think there, there should
be national and international level org-,
interfaith organizations that focus on high
schools. And at the end of the day, you know,
our hope, the wonderful thing about college
students is that they become college graduates
and then they go off and they take their message
and knowledge base and skill set into whatever
they do. And hopefully, a lot of them become
high school teachers.
>>memberfemale5: Haha. Ok.
>>Patel: Cool.
>>memberfemale5: Ok, and maybe the last one,
this is something that we're currently having
a lot of trouble with our work on, because
we're doing things education, but other than
online, just like, if there's any way to get
it into curriculum, you know--
>>Patel: Yeah.
>>memberfemale5: I mean, then you, you hit
into--
>>Patel: Yeah, yeah.
>>memberfemale5: that's kind of like the thought
process--
>>Patel: Yeah.
>>memberfemale5: that's difficult to change.
>>Patel: You know, we do that at the college
level, you know--
>>memberfemale5: Right, right.
>>Patel: like, we help faculty shape new courses
in interfaith cooperation. I just finished
teaching a course at Northwestern University
called Interfaith Leadership, and we're trying
to spread that course, so, and then again,
we hope the theory of change is that campuses
serve as a vanguard sector and as they teach
courses in interfaith cooperation, high schools
start to do that.
>>memberfemale5: Right, right, true. Thank
you very much.
>>Patel: Thank you. Thanks for having me,
again. Thank you so much.
[applause]